[JAZZ MUSIC]
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Hi, I'm
Priyanka Vergadia, a developer
advocate for Google
Cloud, and in this video,
I will unbox Google
Cloud for you.
Let's say, you are a Cloud
architect for foo.com.
How would you build
foo.com on Google Cloud?
There are many different ways
of achieving the same goal,
and no one way is
right or wrong.
Let's use this example
to unbox Google Cloud
and to see some
of the approaches.
By the end of this
demo, you will
understand how to navigate
the Google Cloud console
and locate components needed
to build any common application
to just compute, storage,
database options, and more
such things.
All right, let's get started.
Well, first thing's first.
If you're logged in to the
console for the first time,
create a project.
A project is required
to use Google Cloud
and forms the basis for
creating, enabling, and using
all the Google Cloud services.
I'm going to use this
one for our demo today.
On the left navigation,
select Billing,
and link your billing account.
You can go to billing
any time for an accurate,
up to date picture
of your Cloud spend.
You can view all products
and learn more about them,
read documentation,
work on a quick start,
and even navigate to
the individual products.
If you prefer to
use the command line
interface from the
top right corner,
you can activate
Cloud Shell, which
is an online terminal
preloaded with utilities
such as the G-Cloud command
line tool, kubectl, and more.
Now that we know how to navigate
through the console, let's look
into unboxing a generic
internet facing application,
foo.com, on Google Cloud.
First, you need a virtual
private cloud, WePC Network,
which provides
managed networking
functionality for all our
Google Cloud resources.
You can see one created
here called foonet
with an automatic subnet.
Inside this network, we
will create our application
infrastructure.
For our app infrastructure,
the web and app servers,
we have multiple options
depending on different factors.
Your options are Cloud Run,
App Engine, Kubernetes Engine,
Compute Engine, and Anthos.
If I choose to
deploy serverless,
then it means more
time spent coding
and less time spent worrying
about infrastructure
and scaling.
The Cloud Run offers the ability
to run serverless containers,
and App Engine is a
managed app platform.
If you want to run
containerized apps,
but with more configuration
and flexibility,
then we would pick GKE.
It helps us deploy containerized
apps with Kubernetes
without much of
a learning curve,
while giving us the control
over the configuration of nodes
we want in our infrastructure.
GKE also offers
Autopilot for when
you need the
flexibility and control,
but have limited ops
and engineering support.
For an application in hybrid
and multi-Cloud platform,
use Anthos.
The maximum control
option is Compute Engine.
It is straight up
virtual machines,
so we can define the
configuration of our machines,
depending on the amount
of memory and CPU we need.
But this control also
means more responsibility
to scale, manage, patch,
and maintain them as needed.
In this demo, we chose
Compute Engine for our web
and application server.
Now, let's see how we set up
Compute Engine to globally auto
scale our foo.com service.
We will see an
instance template,
which we call foo-template.
Instance templates are saved
virtual machine configurations
used to create identical VMs.
We need a template,
because we need
the service to be created in
multiple parts of the world as
needed.
In this template,
you can see the type
of machine, networking,
storage, disk information,
and any custom metadata.
We can either create
these identical VMs
individually or as a part
of managed instance groups.
Here, you can also
see that this instance
template is used by three
managed instance groups.
If you click on any of them,
or navigate to instance groups
on the left, you will see all
the managed instance groups
in three different zones--
Asia, Europe, and US.
Autoscaling is set to HTTP
load balancing utilization
of 80%, which brings me
to our load balancing.
Load balancers distribute
traffic to the servers.
They can be applied
to both external web
servers and internal
application servers.
Under Network Services, you
will see load balancing.
Here, we have created a
load balancer with our three
instance groups as backends.
While setting end
data in this video
may be different from
the demo project,
the concepts and guidance apply.
Cloud load balancing
is a fully distributed
and software defined system.
It can literally respond to
over millions queries per second
and is based on any
past IP address.
What does that mean?
Well, it means that we
can define our frontend
infrastructure with
a single IP address.
And our global users coming
from Asia, US, and Europe
will be served their request
from a server that is
as close to them as possible.
This is what our service looks
like behind that single load
balancing IP address.
It also offers
internal load balancing
for our internal
application servers
and offers layer four TCP
and UDP load balancing.
Right at the load
balancer, we have an option
to enable Cloud CDN to cache
the frequently requested media
and web content closer to
the user and the nearest edge
location.
This reduces latency
and optimizes
for last mile performance
for our users.
It also saves cost by fielding
the request right at the edge
without needing to
send to the backend.
And Cloud CDN would
be caching content
stored in Cloud Storage,
our object store, where
we store all of our
media assets, CSS,
JavaScript-- basically,
everything static in nature.
This means that the image
we used on our web page
is being served from cache.
While we are on the topic
of network services,
Cloud DNS is Google's
infrastructure
for high volume
authoritative DNS serving,
which offers 100% SLA,
meaning it never goes down.
It uses our global network
for any past name servers
to serve the DNS zones
from redundant locations
around the world,
providing high availability
and low latency for the users.
Foo.com might have some
media processing functions
for processing images
and video files.
It can be deployed on
Cloud Functions, which
is a serverless function as a
service that scales as needed
and can be triggered
via HTTP, Cloud
Storage, and other services.
For asynchronous
messaging services,
we will use hubsub, send
messages to a topic.
And servers could
subscribe to that topic
to receive those messages and
send out the notifications.
Now, coming to databases,
we have a few choices here.
For relational databases, we
have Cloud SQL and Spanner,
which are both managed.
For generic SQL needs,
MySQL, Postgres, and SQL
Server Cloud SQL is perfect.
Spanner is best for massive
scale relational databases
that need horizontal scaling.
It also supports strong
consistency and asset
transactions.
I would say, you
use Spanner when
you need the benefits
of both relational
and non-relational databases.
For non-relational
databases, we've
got three major options,
Filestore, Bigtable,
and Memory Store.
The Firestore is a serverless
document database that can be
used as DB-as-a-service,
easy to set up,
and provides fast results to
complex queries in real time.
It also supports
offline data and syncs,
which make it a great
choice for mobile use
cases along with
Web, IoT, and gaming.
Bigtable, on the other
hand, is a wide column
no SQL database
that supports heavy
reads and writes with
extremely low latency.
This makes it a perfect
choice for events, time series
data from IoT devices,
click streams,
add events, fraud,
recommendations,
and other personalization
related use cases.
Memory Store is a fully
managed in-memory data
store service for Redis and
Memcached at Google Cloud.
It is best for in-memory
and transient data stores,
offers extremely low latency
and high performance.
Memory Store is great for
web and mobile gaming,
leaderboards, social, chats, and
newsfeed type applications that
require in-memory
database caches as well.
Next part of the
puzzle is analytics.
We usually have real time
and batch data to ingest.
Real time data could be
content from servers,
such as click stream data
or from IoT device sensors.
Batch data could
be from your logs.
Now, these are,
obviously, just examples.
Once the data is ingested,
we process and enrich it
to clean it up and make it
ready for downstream systems,
then store it in a data
warehouse for further analysis.
A data warehouse is a storage
where you keep processed data.
The data analysts
then analyze the data
and create dashboards
for broader consumption.
Data scientists can pick up that
data from the data warehouse
and use it for creating
machine learning
models to generate predictions.
You could also
directly ingest data
from storage systems
for ML models.
We can ingest the batch
data from Cloud storage
and real time data from
applications using Pub/sub,
which is a serverless messaging
service that scales to ingest
millions of events per second.
Now, data flow can then be used
for processing and enriching
the batch and streaming data.
It's based on open
source Apache Beam.
If you are in the Hadoop
ecosystem, then use Dataproc.
It is managed Hadoop
and Spark platform
that is set up to
analyze the data faster,
instead of worrying
about managing
and standing up your
own Hadoop cluster.
It literally spins up a
cluster in 90 seconds.
BigQuery is a serverless
data warehouse
that can also act as long
term storage and a data lake.
We can run SQL queries
to analyze our data
within BigQuery, and it
literally queries over
petabytes of data and
responds in seconds
due to the underlying separation
of storage and compute,
which is unique to BigQuery.
We can use this
data from BigQuery
to create a dashboard in
Looker and Data Studio.
It also offers machine
learning capabilities,
so we can create
machine learning models
and make predictions by just
writing some SQL statements.
Now, for ML and AI projects,
we can use the data in BigQuery
or Cloud storage to train
our models in Vertex AI.
Or we can import our
media files, image,
and other unstructured data
from Cloud storage as well.
In machine learning
and AI, our options
depend on whether we want to
create our own custom model
or use a pre-trained model.
My recommendation is to always
start with a pre-trained model,
see if it works
for your use case.
The most common
use cases are all
covered, including images,
text, video, and tabular data.
If a pre-trained model does
not work for your use case,
then use the AutoML
model in Vertex AI
to train a custom model
on your own data set.
AutoML supports all
the common use cases.
You can evaluate the
model and look at metrics
to improve your model.
It deploys the model
for you and provides you
with an EPI endpoint.
In case you have lots of machine
learning and data science
expertise in-house,
that is only when
I would say, write
your own custom model
code in the framework
of your choice,
such as TensorFlow,
PyTorch, and then
train your model on a prebuilt
or a custom container.
For operations, monitoring,
debugging, and troubleshooting,
Cloud Operations Suite
offers all the tools
needed to keep track of the
resources and applications.
When it comes to
security, understand
that security in Cloud is
a shared responsibility.
Google Cloud offers the
inherent infrastructure security
and the tools that
you would need
to protect your application,
data, and your software.
The data is already encrypted
at rest and in transit.
You can also bring your own
custom keys for encryption too.
For data loss prevention and
protecting PII information,
you have DLP, which helps mask
and tokenize sensitive data
in BigQuery, Cloud Storage,
or even on premises.
For user authentication,
you have Cloud Identity,
which checks if the user
is who they say they are.
And for authorization,
you have Cloud IAM,
where you can define
who has access to what.
Security Command
Center continuously
monitors your Google Cloud
environment for visibility
into the system,
discover vulnerabilities,
detect threats, and
show that, so you
can take actions on them.
There are lots of
other security features
that I did not dive into here.
But go ahead and
play around when
you create your own project.
We just took a tour of most
of the Google Cloud services
for an example
application, foo.com.
We looked at some services for
networking, compute storage,
databases, data analytics,
machine learning, security,
and operations.
There is definitely a
lot more to explore.
But I am confident this
will get you started
with the right background.
Now, it's your turn.
I encourage you to sign
up for a free trial
and follow this
tutorial yourself.
[JAZZ MUSIC]